بالنسبة لي ، كوني مسلما أمريكيا
هو مجرد جزء من
النسيج الثقافي والديني ، فسيفساء
جعلت من هذا البلد الاستثنائي
إحدى التجارب الأخيرة التي مررت
بها أثناء جولة محاضرة في
الجامعة التي كان لي فيها رجل نبيل أكبر سنًا.
بالنسبة لي
رجل أبيض من الغرب الأوسط وقال
إنك تعلم أنه نشأ كمسيحي
وترك الكنيسة ثم قرأ
كتابي عن يسوع ودفعه
للعودة إلى الكنيسة لتأكيد
إيمانه المسيحي وأعتقد أن هناك
شيء جميل جدًا عن قيام مسلم
بتأليف كتاب عن يسوع
يقنع مسيحيًا ساقطًا
بالعودة إلى المسيح لي ، هذا كثيرًا
عن ماهية هذا البلد ، إنها قصص من
هذا القبيل أعتقد أنها تمنحني
الثقة لمعرفة ذلك بغض النظر عن
أي تعصب أو كراهية للأجانب
صادفنا في الوقت الحالي
أننا في النهاية سنجتمع
معًا ونجد الوحدة في تنوعنا